quel smartphone venir acheter au mois de
janvier 2024 vous allez voir bah oui
changement d'année bonne année à tous
soyez heureuse soyez heureux le meilleur
la santé la joie les amis la famille et
de très jolis smartphon et beaucoup de
tech de la tch cool ça c'est bien alors
on débute cette année avec plein de
nouveautés qui arrivent au mois de
janvier c'est une photo un instanté bien
évidemment quand je tourne cette vidéo
on est le 5 janvier l'anniversaire de ma
sœur je t'aime bon anniversaire Delphine
et il y a certains smartphones que je ne
vous recommanderai pas alors que je
voulaai recommander le mois dernier
pourquoi tout simplement parce que il y
a leurs petit frères ou leurs petites sœ
qui sortent ce mois-ci directement il va
donc y avoir du nouveau du côté de chez
Xiaomi avec les redmi redmi note pardon
du côté de chez poco Samsung Galaxy S
qui vont sortir également le Magic 6
Lite de H Nord le rock Phone 8 bref
plein de nouveautés donc ça oblige à
venir faire des choix directement on va
donc regarder quel smartphone venir
acheter on les classe bien évidemment
par catégorie moins de 200 balles 200 à
500 500 900 plus de 900 on va faire
ensuite le gaming on va sortir une
catégorie les iphonees sera une
catégorie à part et puis on va rentrer
une tout toute nouvelle catégorie les
smartphones pour les seniors parce que
oui les seniors ont également besoin de
smartphone et donc c'est un sujet
extrêmement intéressant allez on
commence tout de suite par les moins de
100 alors c'est une marque que je vous
ai présenté le mois dernier c'est la
marque SPC qui est une marque espagnole
un smartphone c'est le SPC Discovery on
est à 119,90 € je tiens à préciser je ne
parle que de smartphon que j'ai eu entre
les mains donc ceux que j'ai pas eu
entre les mains on ne les regarde pas
ici grosse dalle parce qu'on veut
regarder des films des séries on n'est
pas en Full HD on est en HD plus 5,5
pouces c'est une dalle IPS bon il y a
tout ce qui va bien il y a 3 Go de RAM
c'est c'est pas la folie mais ça
conviendra il y a une batterie qui est
correcte 4500 ça ira c'est pas un truc
de fou mais pour avoir un premier
smartphone qui est très bien le design
est sympa 119,90 € si c'est d'ailleurs
un de ces smartphones vous intéresse je
vous mets les liens juste en bas dans la
description comme je vous le disais on
va pas parler des redmi notes redmi note
12 4G redmi note 12 5G tout simplement
et bien parce que on a ce mois-ci des
nouveautés qui vont arriver du côté de
chez poco enfin c'est par là que ça
arrive toute façon les redmi notes donc
on attend tranquillement que le redmi
note 13 Arve je vais pas vous
recommander aujour aujourd'hui un
smartphone qui valait le même prix il y
a un mois il y a 2 mois quelque chose
près alors que la nouvelle génération
arrive donc pour l'instant on reste
tranquille sur tout ce qui est Xiaomi
redmi note on en parle pas en 2024 quel
que soit le smartphone que vous allez
prendre soyez malin dans l'utilisation
de vos smartphone pour venir payer des
choses moins chères et même profiter de
service gratuitement je vous explique
vous pouvez par exemple regarder des
matchs de foot ou de la Formule 1
gratuitement payer moins cher un
abonnement YouTube Premium ou encore
Netflix mais aussi profiter de billets
d'avion de location de voiture et de
voyage en tout genre moins cher et tout
ça est rendu possible grâce au
partenaires de cette vidéo qui est
norvpn puisque norvpn va venir changer
virtuellement l'emplacement de votre
smartphone bien que vous soyez par
exemple connecté en France et bien on
pourra dire que vous êtes connecté en
Turquie vous permettra de profiter des
tarifs moins cher mais ça va bien plus
loin que ça puisque norvpen va venir
assurer la sécurité de votre smartphone
et ça dans plein d'usages différents par
exemple vous êtes en déplacement vous
êtes dans un hôtel vous êtes dans un
resto dans un Magdo que SAJE encore et
vous vous connectez avec vos smartphone
au Wii public attention au pirates qui
pourrait venir récupérer vos donnner de
navigation et bien norvpen va venir
créer un tunnel crypté et totalement
sécurisé qui va vous assurer un anonymat
et qui va venir totalement protéger
votre navigation si par exemple vous
voulez venir télécharger quelque chose
sur votre smartphone et bien norvpn va
venir bloquer les téléchargements
suspects et quand on sait qu'il y a
énormément de tentatives de fishing
notamment au travers des réseaux sociaux
et bien c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
et puis norvpen va venir scanner le Dark
web à la recherche de vos informations
personnelles pour être sûr que si
quelque chose a fuité vous soyez alerté
comme ça il sera temps de venir changer
votre mot de passe en plus de ça grâce à
ben pouvez venir connecter jusqu'à six
appareils en simultané et vous êtes
satisfait ou remboursés sous 30 jours et
ce qui est cool c'est que en ce début
d'année il y a énormément d'OF canon
directement chez N VPN je vous invite à
venir cliquer sur le lien qui est juste
en bas dans la description pour être
encore plus malin avec votre smartphone
et venir également vous protéger on
passe donc tout de suite dans la
catégorie des 200 à 500 balles on va
regarder du côté de chez Samsung
puisqueune fois de plus les redmi notes
on les regarde pas pour l'instant alors
chez Samsung vous allez voir que c'est
c'est vraiment intéressant pourquoi
parce que il y a des nouveautés qui ont
fait leur apparition alors le Galaxy
a05s je ne l'ai pas vu je ne le connais
pas donc j'en parle pas alors vous me
direz c'est pareil pour le A25
connaissant les smartphones de Samsung
ici je suis pas très inquiet en fait
vous avez cette gamme qui est
relativement intéressante chez Samsung
avec le A14 4G qui a 219 €. c'est que de
la 4G ici c'est pas un smartphone 5G
vous avez ensuite son grand frère en 5G
qui a 299 € moi je n'irai pas sur ce
smartphone pourquoi parce que si vous
regardez vous avez le Galaxy A25 5G qui
est à 319 € vous avez 20 balles d'écart
pour 20 balles d'écart ça vaut quand
même le coup regardez on vient les
comparer directement là le A14 là le A25
5G à configuration équivalente he 128
128 bon même si on a un pros qui est un
peu plus rapide ici ça pas bien changer
l'histoire non plus vous avez surtout un
ultra grand temps qui passe en 8
mégapixel au-delà du 2 mégapixel c'est
quand même pas dégueu ici vous avez un
peu plus de mémoire 6 Go versus 4 ça
être plus fluide bon même batterie
quasiment la même résolution au niveau
de l'écran et surtout on passe d'une
dalle LCD à une dalle Super AMOLED donc
c'est quand même plus intéressant pour
20 balles d'écart deevenenir sur le A25
5G plutôt que sur le A14 5G reste dans
la course chez Samsung le Galaxy A34 5G
le Galaxy A54 5G on des smartphones qui
se renouvellent plus tard dans l'année
donc on peut continuer à venir
recommander à 100 balles d'écart bien
évidemment à 100 € d'écart on en aura
pour son argent à peu près la même dalle
hein 6,4 6,3 on ira un peu plus loin en
photo avec un capteur de 50 versus 48 et
12 au niveau d'ultra grand tle versus 8
ici un peu plus de mémoire vie
fatalement donc un smartphone qui sera
un peu plus fluide même taille de
batterie et dans les deux cas une dalle
Super AMOLED donc si vous n'avez pas la
somme de 499 € de quasiment 500 balles
vous pouvez aller sur le A34 qui n'a pas
à rougir ici et qui reste malgré tout un
très bon smartphone autre smartphone que
j'aime toujours et que je recommande
encore plus alors cette année c'est
peut-être la dernière fois que je vais
venir le recommander parce qu'il va
commencer à être déclassé c'est un
smartphone de 2022 c'est le noing phone
one avec la glyf interface qui est très
particulière c'est une des des rares
smartphones la plupart du temps lorsque
je viens parler de smartphone sont des
smartphones qui sont de l'année en cours
je parle rarement de smartphon des
années antérieures sans quoi ça serait
vraiment trop compliqué une vraie usine
à gaz mais celui-là de par son design
très à part de par ce que propose noing
au niveau de la glyf interface
c'est-à-dire ce design au niveau du dos
qu'on peut venir utiliser pour
différentes choses on peut venir
personnaliser les sonneries
personnaliser les affichages il y a une
expérience qui est très à part je l'aime
beaucoup je trouve très très très bien
il est à 329 € on est sur un Snapdragon
778 g plus qui reste malgré tout actuel
et qui va bien écran 120 Hz AMOLED
caméra principal de 50 mégapixel c'est
pas le meilleur en photo mais si vous
cherchez quelque chose de très à part de
très différent vous pouvez y aller parce
qu'en terme de design il est absolument
incroyable alors j'ai un super bon plan
à vous soumettre également le pixel 7a
de Google il est à 509 € et donc dans la
catégorie supérieure des 500 à 900 €
mais là regardez j'ai trouvé une offre
hyper canon chez Amazon il est à 419 €
on a 90 € d'écart - 18 % franchement ça
vaut le coup c'est super bien il est en
plus de ça expédié et vendu par Amazon
vous êtes tranquille vous le recevez
rapidement et ça s'il y a bien un
smartphone à venir recommander
aujourd'hui à moins de 500 balles avec
un double capteur photo B il y en a
qu'un qu'on voilà mais il y a un de deux
capteurs photo grand angle et ultra
grand angle il y a pas de téléobjectif
et bien c'est bien celui-là c'est un
excellent photophone un excellent
smartphone avec toute l'expérience
logicielle de Google toute
l'intelligence artificielle de Google
qu'on a à l'intérieur la p tensor G2 qui
marche bien bref très très bon
smartphone à un peu moins de 500 balles
je viens le recommander plus plus plus
plus plus et en smartphone qui est cool
et qui est un tarif assez intéressant
c'est le Honor 90 12 Go de RAM 512 Go de
stockage très fluide un peu moins de 500
balles
499,90 € gros capteur de 200 mgapixel
plein de techno pour venir lutter contre
la fatigue oculaire et croyez-moi c'est
important grosse batterie la Dragon 7
Gen 1 il est très bien un peu moins de
500 balles il reste très actuel et c'est
vraiment un smartphone que je peux venir
recommander et qu'on peut venir utiliser
ici les yeux fermés et puis un autre
petit dernier qui est très sympa j'adore
le dos ici coloris j'ai préféré celui-là
le canil Bay ce dos est hyper canon je
vous l'avais déjà présenté il y a pas
très longtemps sur Youtube j'adore ce
smartphone c'est le Motorola hedge40 Neo
Motorola est venu s'améliorer au niveau
des photos si vous voulez un smartphone
américain à 399 € vous pouvez aller sur
le Motorola Edge 40 Neo qui est aussi
une très très jolie proposition on se
fait un petit tour par les smartphones
de gaming avant d'arriver dans les 500
900 balles je qu'onarle un peu de gaming
tout de suite on va pas aller chez poco
tout de suite sur la série X par ce qui
vous le marque ici série X et M6 qui
sort le 11 janvier alors on va attendre
tranquillement on en reparlera de ces
smartphones au mois de février donc bien
évidemment abonnez-vous à la chaîne si
c'est pas déjà le cas comme ça vous
saurez tout sur les nouveautés qui vont
arriver on peut se parler encore par
contre de la série F qui reste actuelle
voyez il y a le F5 pro et le F5 sur le
F5 vous avez un Snapdragon 7 plus gen 2
qui reste très très bien un grand écran
AMOLED voilà c'est du 6,67 pouces
technologie de refroidissement qui va
bien derrière bon après voyez vous avez
toutes les techn qui vont bien ufs 3.1
lpddr5 l'extension virtuelle de RAM
également l'appareil photo il est au
fraise on l'achète pas ici pour venir
faire des photos parce que franchement
vous allez être déçu il est surtout
assez léger assez fin ça c'est quand
même bien et puis il a un très joli
design vous avez son grand frère le
modèle Pro où on va forcément plus loin
processeur plus rapide Snapdragon 8 plus
Gen 1 l'écran 2K toujours 120 Hz de la
recharge rapide 30 W les caméras on
passe on est un peu plus cher à 459,90 €
tandis que de l'autre côté vous voyez il
y a une promo à
379, 90 donc ça c'est vrai que pour un
smartphone de gaming il y a 100 balles
d'écart ça vaut vraiment le coup d'aller
sur le poco F5 aujourd'hui parce qu'il
est quand même vraiment bien actuel à
moins de 400 balles c'est très très
maîtrisé et vous avez le poco F5 pro qui
à 459 qui était à 629 voyez il y a aussi
une très très jolie promo ici quasiment
200 € 180 € d'écart ça vaut vraiment le
coup pas tout à fait mais enfin ça vaut
le coup refroidissement ufs 3.1 pddr5
également au niveau de de du stockage ah
puis cet écran surtout 2 k ça c'est
quand même vachement bien après un tarif
qui reste quand même très canon sur le
gaming vous avez une nouveauté c'est le
Red Magic 9 pro il est juste là alors il
a toute une expérience qui est très très
cool chez eux au niveau de l'unboxing
mais ça je vous le laisserai découvrir
par vous-même lorsque vous l'achèterz si
vous voulez venir l'acheter c'est un
smartphone qui est vraiment très
atypique très joli j'aime beaucoup il a
un super design voyez avec ce bloc photo
là vous avez deux boutons ici pour venir
jouer on va retrouver un petit slider là
bouton là également ça c'est pour
l'allumer l'éteindre là vous avez les
boutons de volume de l'autre côté il y a
rien c'est un peu épais par contre comme
smartphone c'est pas le plus fin du
monde mais en terme d'expérience de
gaming il est vraiment très bien vous
avez en plus de ça une prise jack sur le
dessus et c'est un smartphone qui tourne
surtout sur le Snapdragon 8 Gen 3 ça
fait vraiment pas marer système de
refroidissement ice 13 écran complet bon
ok il vous raconte un peu l'histoire
c'est de la moled double batterie de
6500 MAMP ça fait pas rigoler et de la
recharge rapide 80 W donc là en terme de
performance en terme de son en terme de
qualité en terme d'affichage vous avez
un très très très très joli smartphone
après petit détail est-ce qu'ils aiment
bien ils vous ont mis un capteur photo
sous l'écran au niveau de la caméra de
selfie il est pas fou ça permettra sur
d'aller encore plus en immersion petit
détail il va venir chauffer un petit peu
et les photos surtout au niveau de la
macro c'est pas dingue dingue mais bon
bon voilà ok normalement ici je vous
parle du rock Phone et je vais pas vous
parler du rock phone tout de suite
pourquoi bah parce que Asus a annoncé le
lancement du rock Phone 8 très bientôt
le 8 janvier à Las Vegas on en reparle
très bientôt du rock Phone 8 donc restez
connectés à la chaîne abonnez-vous c'est
pas déjà fait on le testera bien
évidemment j'adore les rock phone ici
mais pour l'instant je vais pas vous
dire de venir acheter le rock Phone 7
tout simplement parce qu'il y a le rock
Phone 8 qui arrive donc ça ne sert à
rien donc pour l'instant on garde en
smartphone de gaming le poco F5 F5 pro
et le Red Magic 9 pro qui est là qui est
très cool également allez on passe dans
la catégorie des 500 à 900 € il y a pas
mal de choses aussi à venir voir ici on
va exclure aussi chez Xiaomi le Xiaomi
13 le Xiaomi 13 pro pourquoi me
direz-vous mon bon monsieur Greux et
bien tout simplement parce que le Xiaomi
14 pro voyez qui est déjà arrivé chez
moi il sortira je pense au mois de
février moi j'ai déjà depuis un petit
moment je m'amuse bien avec mais pour
l'instant on en parle pas on le garde de
côté donc tout ce qui va être Xiaomi 13
un peu compliqué de venir les
recommander aujourd'hui par contre celui
que je peux venir recommander et qui est
très très bien chez Xiaomi c'est le 13t
qui reste très cool il était à 649 € 90
il tombe à 549,90 € c'est quand même
vachement bien et vous avez le modèle
Pro également qui est à
799,9 celui que j'aais recommander c'est
plus le Xiaomi 13t avec ce tarif là il
est quand même hyper canon on a le bloc
module qui a été travaillé avec Leica le
grand écran 144 Hz pour le gaming c'est
très bien bon la recharge rapide 67 W ça
on connait ça marche toujours très très
bien chez Xiaomi on est chez un chez
mediatch avec un dim City 8200 ultra qui
fait très bien laffire il est assez
polyvalent en terme de photo ça va bien
50 mgapixel vous avez un télé 50
mégapixel également Leica et un ultra
grand angle de 12 mégapixel et forcément
sur le Modelle pro on ira plus loin avec
un miatch demman city 9200 plus toujours
un écran AMOLED 144 Hz breftion le
savoir-faire de Xiaomi qui est très bien
très bon très maîtrisé toujours 50
mégapixel objectif LEICA ici sur la
caméra principale téléobjectif 50
mégapixel avec Leica et cet ultra grand
angle de 12 mgapixel donc en terme de
photo il est cool vous avez différents
looks il sont pas mal aussi he qu'on
avait déjà les looks avec les LICA Leica
authentique et Leica vibrant qui sont
pas mal comme ça vous choisissez votre
colorimétrie et ce que vous aimez en
terme d'image et d'émotion et il reste
vraiment très très bien avec du 35 du 50
et du 90 donc il a de quoi faire ici en
terme de photo are smartphone qui est
bien positionné chez Motorola c'est le
Edge 40 599 €. j'aime bien ce smartphone
je trouve plutôt bien bien fait assez
malin avec une bonne stabilisation au
niveau du shooting en vidéo ça c'est pas
mal même si la vidéo c'est pas là où il
va être le meilleur batterie de 4400 ça
tient la route de la recharge rapide 68
W miaatek diman City 8000 0 bon ça
marche un smartphone que j'ai adoré
c'est le Asus le zenphone 10 pourquoi
parce qu'il est tout petit il tient très
bien en main ils ont fait un tarif 699 €
au lieu de 799 €. l'idée ici c'est
d'avoir un smartphone de moins de 6
pouces au niveau de la taille de l'écran
qui tient très bien en main sans perdre
de place 5,9 pouces stabilisation
optique au niveau de votre caméra
principale Snapdragon 8 gen 2
extrêmement performant je l'adore
j'adore le design j'adore les photos il
est vraiment vraiment bien donc si vous
cherchez un smartphone compact vous
allez les yeux fermés sur le zenphone 10
d'Asus en plus il y a plein d'options
logiciel qui vient maximiser
l'expérience et notamment en terme
d'économie d'énergie et au niveau de la
sauvegarde de votre batterie donc c'est
vraiment vraiment bien are smartphone
qui est sorti il y a pas longtemps qui
est très bien chez Samsung c'est le
Galaxy S23 F 699 € on est dans la gamme
S il y aura pas de S24 fe tout de suite
ça c'est vraiment un produit qui sort
plus tard dans l'année il y aura
peut-être d'ailleurs jamais de S24 fe
mais celui-là il est vraiment vraiment
vraiment chouette avec un design qui
reprend le design de la gamme S bien
qu'on verra d'ici quelques jours ce qui
arrivera avec les S24 ça se trouve ça
sera différent mais vu les rumeurs a
priori pas trop corningoria glace 5 à
avant à l'arrière cadre en alu bon ok au
niveau de la photo c'est polyvalent
capteur principal de 50 ultra grand tle
de 12 téléobjectif de 8 avec un zoom
optique x 3 c'est convenable il y a
plein d'options au niveau de la photo au
niveau de la vidéo qu'on aime beaucoup
ici chez Samsung surtout un écran
dynamic AMOLED 2x qui est extrêmement
bon chez Samsung dans la gamme S il est
magnifique très lumineux même en plein
jour bref je vous en ai parlé sur
Youtube allez voir ma vidéo si vous le
connaissez pas 699 9 € c'est aussi un
très joli smartphone alors je dirais
peut-être attendez quelques jours de
voir si le S23 va pas baisser davantage
avec l'arrivée du S24 c'est possible
peut-être que les tarifs vont être
légèrement réajustés par Samsung mais
pour l'instant en tout cas en l'état ça
reste un très joli smartphone autre
produit que j'aime beaucoup le noing
phone 2 noing phone 2 avec nosing OS 2.0
bien évidemment la glyf interface vous
expliquz c'est le design que vous allez
retrouvé au niveau de l'arrière de votre
smartphone un écran ltpo amolet de 6,7
pouces et puis un Snapdragon 8 plus Gen
1 donc très performant en photo c'est
pas le meilleur mais il reste très bien
super bien fini j'adore ce produit donc
ça ça vaut vraiment le coup de venir le
découvrir il est tombé à 629 € au lieu
de 729 € si vous voulez un smartphone
rapide efficace 12 Go de RAM 256 629 €
avec un design très atypique vous allez
sur le noing phone 2 les yeux fermés un
smartphone qui est cool 799 € c'est le
pixel 8 pixel 8 de Google double capteur
photo grand angle ultra grand angle vous
avez toute l'expérience avec toute
l'intelligence artificielle que nous
propose Google ici et qui est absolument
magnifique très bel écran on peut faire
énormément de choses avec alors il y a
le pro mais le pro il est plus cher
celui-là il est déjà vraiment vachement
bien plus Google tensor G3 derrière
enfin bref si vous voulez un smartphone
que vous aimez Google dopé à
l'intelligence artificielle vous allez
les yeux fermés sur le pixel 8 qui est
vraiment un excellent produit vous venez
regarder mettre des sourires quand les
gens font la gueule enfin le truc est
top j'adore vraiment toutes l' qu'ils
ont mis à l'intérieur c'est juste un
excellent smartphone produit très à part
chez crossc c'est le Stella X5 le
stellar X5 il est intéressant si vous
cherchez un smartphone un peu différent
un smartphone durable un smartphone qui
va aller loin dans le temps qui a
pourtant les dernières techno wifi 6e
bien évidemment de la 5G avec le fameux
Xlink de crossc où on peut venir
attacher son smartphone très facilement
il y a plein d'accessoires qu'on peut
avoir aussi bien pour le B2B que pour un
usage personnel qui reste avec un design
de crossc qui est très très très sympa
qui se prend bien en main qu'on peut
utiliser comme un ordinateur bref ici ce
qu'on cherche c'est d'avoir un produit
durable fait par une boîte française et
ça quand même c'est vachement bien on
peut aller sous l'eau on peut venir
faire de la vidéo sous l'eau je l'ai
fait je peux vous le dire on peut venir
faire des photos très facilement on
vient loquer l'écran ce qui fait que
toutes les commandes tactiles ne
poseront aucun problème vous avez des
boutons dédiés pour changer de mode
Photo et Vidéo pour lancer le shooting
c'est vraiment un très joli smartphone
une très jolie proposition donc si vous
voulez un truc que soit pour l' out d'or
pour travailler un produit qui est un
peu à la croisée des chemins alors il
vaut presque 900 balles
899,90 € mais c'est vraiment un très
joli produit aussi allez je vous le
présente bien qu'il estit son grand
frère qui qui arrive d'ici un mois et
demi peut-être c'est le moment où Honor
sort son gamme sa gamme Magic 6 on
devrait voir arriver le Magic 6 pro
normalement au mois de février il y a
déjà le 6 slide qui se profile je vous
déjà présenté très rapidement l'autre
jour lors d'un re sur Instagram on le
présente très rapidement sur Youtube en
vidéo le Magic 5 Pro reste quand même
actuel parce que même si le Magic 6 est
présenté au mois de février s' garde le
même calendrier il devrait être
disponible à partir du mois de mai donc
ça laisse un peu de temps au Magic 5 Pro
pour continuer à exister surtout un
tarif de
999,90 € ça reste un bon smartphone avec
un Snapdragon 8 gen 2 qui reste malgré
tout très actuel encore en 2024 très
performant très fluide plein de belles
techno à l'intérieur personnellement
c'est un smartphone que j'aime
énormément que je trouve magnifique en
photo et qui sera toujours très très bon
cette année un très grand écran plein de
belles techno triple capteur photo
arrière de 50 mégapixel très grosse
batterie de 5100 mamph il est juste
topissime donc si vous avez un budget à
un peu moins de 1000 balles on peut y
aller alors vous l'avez compris on
parlera pas ici des nouveaux Samsung
Galaxy S on en parlera au mois de
février parce qu'ils vont être annoncés
très bientôt on va quandême regarder
dans les produits à plus de 1000 balles
on a le pixel 8 Pro qui est très bon que
j'ai vraiment vraiment adoré 1099 €
c'est un certain prix j'en conviens mais
tout ce qu'on peut faire d'ailleère avec
de la des photos tout est magnifique
l'écran est top l'autonomie est bonne
c'est un très très joli smartphone si
vous avez un peu plus de 1000 balles et
que vous aimez Google et que vous
utiliser les services Google et bien
vous pouvez y aller ici les yeux fermés
on va faire un tour du côté des iPhones
alors du côté des iPhones one ça reste
toujours très beau très belles
évolutions ici et pas de mauvaise
surprise et l'iPhone se reste toujours
un peu compliqué à venir recommander
parce que même s'il a un tarif très très
canon on a l'ancien design d'Apple ici
mais le tarif de 529 € fait qu'on peut
venir se poser des questions après ce
que je recommande c'est le 128 599 €
mais c'est vrai que à ce tarif là
préférais mettre plus d'argent aller sur
un iPhone 13 je peux en trouver en
reconditionné dans des conditions super
intéressantes et puis après vous avez
compris l'histoire plus vous rajoutez
d'argent plus vous en avez pour votre
argent le 14 reste bien le 15 également
le 15 pro aussi moi j'utilise un 15 pro
max depuis quelques temps j'en suis très
satisfait il est très bien surtout la
force ici c'est iOS mais je pense que le
très bon compromis c'est probablement
l'iPhone 14 869 € il est vraiment cool
et si vous retrouvez les iPhone 13 en
reconditionné à pas trop cher vraiment
ça va être une bonne affaire autre
catégorie de produits dont on avait pas
parlé donc on commence à parler
aujourd'hui sur les smartphones pour
senior et là j'ai reçu le produit d'une
marque que je ne connaissais pas c'est
la marque binom alors je pense que ça se
dit binom et pas binom mais c'est une
marque française vous le voyez là dans
les marques pour seniior je connaissais
Doro que ma grand-mère avait que ma mère
avait également mais la marque binom m'a
l'air d'être extrêmement intéressante
alors ils font plein de choses ils font
des smartphones ils font des téléphones
à touches il y a aussi des bracelets
alarme parce qu'on parle ici au seniors
et que parmi les seniors les personnes
les plus âgées ont besoin de système de
sécurité chez eux et parmi leurs
produits il y a celui-là qui est
intéressant c'est le SX1 si vous n'êtes
pas senior je pense que ce genre de
design vous fera un petit peu peur 229 €
moi ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
que vous avez un bouton SOS là voyez
donc quelqu'un une personne âgée qui
pourrait tomber ou se sentir mal pour
appuyer dessus à condition qu'elle avec
elle sinon il y a les bracelets il y a
des téléalarmes qui existent également
ça c'est quand même pas mal parce que
comme vous êtes sur de grosses icônes
voyez et bien une personne du 3è âge
comprendra très facilement ce qu'elle a
à faire téléphone photos message
appareil photo alors je commence à le
découvrir je l'ai reçu il y a pas très
longtemps mais je trouve que il répond à
un marché on se parle ici de 4g on peut
avoir WhatsApp dessus bien évidemment et
que on se parle ici d'une marque
française qui est dans le sud de la
France qui vont proposer différents
produits pour les seniors donc quand ils
m'ont contacté j'ai dit envoyez-moi ça
je trouve ça assez marrant assez
intéressant en fait he donc après je
vous laisserai aller jeter un coup d'œil
une fois de plus je vous mets le lien
juste en bas dans la description allez
on termine avec les smartphones qui se
plient le leader c'est Samsung avec son
Galaxy Z Philip 5 qui est magnifique
1199 € je vous en ai déjà parlé sur
youtube il est incroyable que ce soit
fermé ouvert il est très très polyvalent
et je continue à l'utiliser et à
beaucoup l'aimer voyez hein c'est juste
un produit qui est top top il a plus de
batterie mais il est cool et je l'aime
vraiment énormément mais il est 1199 €
alors il y en avait un qui m'avait
beaucoup plus cette année qui est un peu
dans la même idée bien que les finitions
soient un peu moins bonnes et bien que
l'expérience logiciel soit un peu moins
bien construite c'est ce que propose
Motorola mais ils ont baissé leur tarif
avec le modèle Pro alors là vous voyez
déjà sur le Razer 40 qui est très cool
mais on en parle dans quelques secondes
on a le Razer 40 ultra à
999 € on économise 200 balles et pour
200 ballle d'écart vous avez aussi un
très joli smartphone très grand écran
très belle finition donc si vous avez
pas le budget pour venir acheter un
Galaxy zflip 5 on peut aller vraiment en
se faisant plaisir sur un Razer 40 ultra
l'expérience sera un peu moins abouti au
niveau de l'usage de l'écran extérieur
de l'écran externe mais pour autant on
aura aussi un très joli smartphone qui
se plie et ça c'est bien et je vous le
montr il y a quelques instants et bien
vous avez le Razer 40 tout court qui
était à 899 qui est passé à 699 moins
200 100 balles c'est énorme alors lui si
on vient le comparer on vient le
comparer au Galaxy zflip 3 qui avait ce
plus petit écran à l'avant mais qui
reste malgré tout très cool que l'on
trouve quand même à 649 € là je suis
chez Darty il est du coup un peu moins
cher que le Razer 40 mais le Razer 40 il
est 2023 tand est- que celui-là il est
2022 après il tourne sur un Snapdragon
888 qui est pas mal qui commence à
vieillir mais qui est pas mal et chez
Motorola on est sur la série 7 première
génération qui va aussi très bien et qui
vous posera aucun problème donc ça c'est
à vous de de faire votre choix avec un
tarif équivalent je me dirais peut-être
que j'irai plus facilement sur le zflip
3 que sur le Razer 40 mais Razer 40 il
est quand même aussi vachement bien bon
et après vous avez le G Galaxy ZF de 5
chez Samsung c'est un autre format
quasiment 1900 balles c'est très cher il
est pas fait pour tout le monde mais il
est aussi extrêmement efficace c'est
très très bien voilà pour ce panorama
des smartphones en janvier 2024 je vous
le dis il y a le Honor Magic 6 Lite qui
sort très très bientôt il y a le Xiaomi
14 pro qui sort également bientôt est
sorti le Red Magic 9 pro pour le gaming
qui est aussi très très bien à vous de
voir lequel vous PL plus bien évidemment
je vous mets tous les liens juste en bas
dans la description et puis d'ailleurs
si vous avez un smartphone de Samsung et
vous voulez savoir comment l'utiliser et
bien je vous ai fait une vidéo est juste
là allez la voir vous serez pas
déçu